قال الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده ستعمل على
تعزيز امنها القومي للحفاظ على استقرارها
اضاف خلال اختتام اعمال مجلس نواب الشعب
ان الصين ستؤسس جيشا قويا ليصبح صورا
فولاذيا يحمي امنها ومصالحها الوطنيه على
حد تعبيرها
وما وصفها بالانشطه الانفصاليه الراميه
لاستقلال الجزيره وقال ان ستعمل على تعزيز
الاستقرار فيه
نؤكد التمسك بمبدا صين واحده وعلى العمل
بنشاط لتعزيز التنميه السلميه للعلاقات
عبر المضيق ومعارضه التدخل الخارجي
والانشطه الانفصاليه الداعيه لاستقلال
تايوان وتعزيز عمليه اعاده توحيد تايوان
مع الصين
قال رئيس الوزراء الصيني الجديد لشينغ ان
بلاده يمكنها تحقيق الكثير من خلال العمل
المشترك مع الولايات المتحده وان الاحتواء
والقمع لا يفيدان اي طرف واضافه في مؤتمر
صحفي ان حجم التجاره بين بيجين و واشنطن
بلغ العام الماضي 760 مليار دولار وهو رقم
قياسي جديد كما اكد ان بلاده حققت المياه
اقتصاديه عاليه خلال السنوات الماضيه
لكنها بحاجه لمضاعفات الجهود لتحقيق هدف
التنميه الاقتصاديه المحدد وهو 5% اضافه
لتمسكها باستقرار الاقتصاد كاولويه امام
التحديات
تنضم الينا من بيجين مراسله الجزيره شيماء
جويئي شيماء في ختامه اجتماع اعمال
مجلس نواب الشعب ما خلاصه خلاصه السياسيه
لنهج الصين في الاعوام القادمه كما لخصت
على لسان الرئيس
او الى الصين وايضا اكد بان هنالك قوى
خارجيه تقوم بدعم قوى انفصاليه داخل وقال
بان الصين تعارض هذه القوى الخارجيه
تعرضها بحزم وبشده وبانها ربما تتخذ خطوات
حاسمه فيما يتعلق بهذا الملف في المستقبل
وهنالك نقطه ثالثه اساسيه ايضا اكد عليها
الرئيس شيشي فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات الدوليه
اشار الشيء اليوم في كلمته الى ان الصين
تريد ان تلعب دورا بناء مع باقي دول
العالم لارساء مزيد من السلام والاستقرار
العالميين وهذا ما يحيلنا سلمى على كلمه
الرئيس شي يوم الجمعه الماضيه عقب اعاده
انتخاب رئيسا للبلاد لولايه ثالثه عندما
تزامن ذلك مع
الاعلان عن الاتفاق السعودي الايراني
بوساطه صينيه ذلك اليوم وهذا ما يؤكد ان
الصين تحاول ان يكون لها دور وساطه دور
لبناء السلام في العالم وايضا هنالك نقطه
اخرى كانت ملف اوكرانيا كونه الصين كانت
قد اعلنت في وقت سابق باشراف من الرئيس
الشيشين به على خطه للسلام او خطه للامن
العالمي كما اطلق عليها حينها
وتناولت الملف الاوكراني تحديدا ومساله
ملف حبوب تصدير ملف حبوب اوكرانيا وكل هذه
الملفات في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ارادت
الصين ايضا ان تلعب دورا بناء في تعزيز
السلام كل هذه النقاط ايضا تطرق اليها
رئيس الوزراء الجديد لتشان سلمى شديد لم
يؤكد على لم تكن لهجته شديده اللهجه فيما
يتعلق بملف تايوان اكد على ضروره التوحيد
وقال بان هناك نقاط مشتركه بين الشعبين
الصيني والتايواني بانهما شعب واحد ولكنه
ركز اكثر في تصريحاته على الجانب
الاقتصادي وعلى ضروره التعاون حتى عندما
تطرق الى ملف العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه
حاول الابقاء في لهجته على ان هنالك
العديد من النقاط المشتركه بين بيجين و
واشنطن للعمل عليها في المستقبل واشار الى
العلاقات التجاريه الجيده بين البلدين
شيماء جويئي مراسلتنا من بيجين شكرا لك